to some great innovators shaking up the
food industry overall in fact food and
wine is out with its second annual game
changers list in the july innovation
issue it features 16 people and
companies changing the way we eat and
drink one of those is new york-based
seltzer company sanzo founded by sandro
rocco it's the first beverage company to
bring an asian fruit flavor to sparkling
water drinkers here in the u.s
we got calamansi lychee alfonso mango
and yuzu with a hit of ginger
found at sanzo in 2019
in queens in my 500 square foot studio
apartment
basically had this idea four years ago
that hey there was this massive wave of
asian and asian american influence you
know across a variety of creative
industries tv film and music but
essentially when i went to the grocery
stores
we didn't quite see that manifest
i grew up in a very diverse area of
central new jersey
we were actually among the first asian
american families in that town a lot of
my upbringing was kind of learning to
assimilate into these various
communities and the big way that we did
that was through adopting cuisine my
comfort food growing up uh was chicken
parm and linguine the origins of sanzo
were trying to basically bridge that
that gap i was growing to like to
embrace my identity tap into my asian
american roots but also provide a source
of discovery or inspiration or
celebration for folks who are not in
that community
this is basically that
in this camp
this one's actually our most popular
most popular flavor folks haven't had it
before it's kind of like a floral berry
grape type of fruit there was very much
this idea embedded in me that how am i
going to pass down my culture without
food and beverage products that i can be
proud of we go into these stores it can
be humbling to see how much more room we
have to go and so we're just excited to
continue building this brand
[Music]
and we're joined now by food and wine's
editor in chief hunter lewis in his
first interview about the game changers
issue uh sanso is terrific by the way i
um i drink one almost every time i go
grocery shopping because it's in the
cooler when i get in line and i'm the
kind of guy who just like has to do
something while he's waiting you crack
it open before you pay you're that guy i
always pay
what's your flavor i've only actually
had this one the asian pear is it
the yuzu yeah
ginger yeah so why was this a game
changer for you guys well number one i
love the name of the company and the the
owner sandro rocco that's a very cool
name so sandro is uh centro and and
sanzo is blowing up right now i mean if
we think about the sparkling water
category and uh and how popular it is at
the supermarket um what we love about
this particular brand is that it's
bringing asian fruit flavors to the to
the mass market
and that had never been done before no
no they uh they saw a niche and uh and
sandro um he took it and now he's in
whole foods and growing quickly yeah
that's terrific um i want to take a sip
of this yeah definitely i was waiting
for it he's like you know okay let's
stand on ceremony
oh that's good oh that's real good you
know what i can add a little something
to this yeah maybe a little tequila a
little mezcal hey now now you're talking
about
when when people think about wine
because i was i think it's very exciting
that dwayne wade made the list oh yeah
yeah you don't think about dwayne wade
and wine but you liked his wine why
what's the name of his wine so wade
sellers is is a great label um dwyane
wade's been making wine in napa for a
few years now and we noticed something a
few years ago lebron and dwayne wade and
carmelo anthony cj mccollum were posting
on instagram about all the wine that
they were trading on on the planes after
games
uh there's a huge culture of wine in the
nba um but why why dwayne wade is a game
changer and he's on the list this year
is because
dwayne joined the board at uc davis um
and and their their wine school which is
world-renowned and
he and several other nba players are
working to make wine more inclusive to
demystify it um you know why not
consider it inclusive you know i think
it could be snobby it can be a hard uh
you know a high barrier of entry and um
through scholarships through mentorship
and through addressing uh inclusivity uh
dwyane wade is changing the game i don't
drink much wine but when i do i just
shop based on the label if i think it's
cool that's good enough for me that's
how you choose literally that's how he
did it he's got a cool label too yes
great uh but a lot of people are not
drinking these days that includes me uh
my wife and i buy a lot of these
non-alcoholic stuff and you've got a
shop on the list that is selling low and
no alcohol beverages tell us about it
there's a shop called no low
they're based here and they've got a
big online retail
we see the the nanohub the drink space
overall is just exploding with
innovation
more r d than probably any corner of the
food industry um but the non-alcoholic
drink space grew by 33 last year so
what's amazing about it is you get
something you can put on the table and
it feels festive it feels like an
occasion but no one feels bad the next
day and also actually it tastes so much
like alcohol you might actually get like
a contact buzz your brain makes a
placebo effect that's amazing yeah
placebo um so i'm a guy i like to change
my diet around every now and then you
know i'm a carnivore i'm a meat eater
but occasionally i'll go vegan so
there's some meat alternatives um that
are on this list tell us about prime
roots and are they really good everybody
says oh it really tastes like meat and i
don't know you got to try it one of them
i will i would like to know what we like
about prime roots is that they celebrate
the culture of meat whether it's the
flavor the texture
they use a product called koji which is
a bacteria used on our fungus on rice
that's used to make sake and soy sauce
it gives really deep rich flavor um and
so their mock meats are made with koji
and it's got a deeper richer flavor
and a texture that is much more like
so i embraced the vegan lifestyle so i'm
going to try it it's so it's a gale will
too i will try it you're right i will
try i'll give it a shot because hunter
said so
giving us some tips on food and wine
also looking very dapper i know nate's
taking the deconstructed suit i knew
nate was here so oh
did you do that yourself hunter
all by yourself good job thank you very
much food and wines july issue hits
newsstands friday